I'm John Clements and I'm the committee chair with Troops 692 in Casabary, Florida.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by patrons like me.
Thanks, Clark. And now to you, Scoutmaster.
So during our last visit to Condorsteg International Scout Center in Condorsteg,
Switzerland, one of my scouts said to me: you know, it would be really cool to be Swiss.
And I said: what makes you say that? And he says: well, the flag is a big plus.
Oh boy, we've done it again. Yes, this is podcast number 306..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag. Brian Hildebrand wrote in about our last podcast,
podcast 305. We discussed John Thurman and the patrol system And in that discussion
I related a story that John Thurman wrote about a brand new patrol in the early,
early days of scouting. And Brian Hildebrand wrote in and said: I really like that story.
The only thing left to imagine is where they got their hands on a scout handbook
And whether their parents even knew that they were going out camping or permitted them to go
that first night. And did the policemen show up? because he saw them out there camping, or
maybe one of their parents sent them looking for them. But this story of scouts before adult
scout involved in it was very interesting. Thanks for all you do for the scouting movement.
Well, thank you, Brian, for getting in touch. Another way to get in touch with us is through
a live chat session And we try to have a couple every week, usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed And we'll let you know when
we're going to be live. at scoutmastercgcom- And a number of people checked in this past
week, We had some lively discussions And, in addition to our frequent fliers who've been on
the chat before, we heard from Sean Sherwin, who's a scout master of Troop 312 in Green River,
Wyoming. Eric Song, who's a training chair in Georgia, Mike Vale, who is with the first Almyra
scout group in Ontario. Rob M, who is a committee chair for PAC 135, an assistant scout master
with Troop 235 in North Plainfield, New Jersey. So come and join us when we have a live chat. We'd
love to hear from you. Over the past couple of weeks I've been talking about seminarcgcom
And this is going to be my take on kind of an interactive training and learning environment
for scouters And to make this feasible, to get it launched, we started working through
patreoncom. I'm going to talk to you more about that in a moment, But I want to let you
know. within the next week or so I want to have the introduction to our first seminar ready
to go, And this one is going to be about challenge learning and achievement in scouting-
And that's a fancy way for saying advancement. But there's a method to that title and it'll
be explained in the introduction. So keep an eye open for that and check us out at Patreon,
because I want to ask a favor of you. If what we're doing has helped you, if you're a regular
reader and listener, you can return the favor in one of two ways. You can support the podcast by
making a one-time payment and become a scoutmastercgcom backer, Or you can make a subscription
payment via Patreon by pledging $5 or more a month. That also helps us get seminarcg
off the ground. if you become a patron through Patreon, There's special premiums available
to anyone who becomes a patron or a backer. So here's how to make either of those things
happen. To become a backer, it's pretty simple: Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link
at the top of the page and you'll find a number of options there that will make you a backer
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Michael Nelson and Laura Hiley, who've become
backers since our last podcast. Now to become a patron, you can click the link to my Patreon
page in the podcast notes or you can go directly to wwwpatreoncom- backslash scoutmastercg. Patreon-
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com backslash scoutmastercg. And if you become a patron or a backer this
week, I'll make sure to thank you personally in our next podcast. Well, the remainder of this
podcast is going to be taken up with a discussion about planning and your patroller's council,
because I get a fair number of questions about that and it was the subject of some of our talk
during the live chat this week And I thought I'd take the opportunity to kind of lay out
some ideas about planning that might help you and your scouts, And that's going to take up the
remainder of the podcast. So let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
The question of scouts, planning and the way the patroller's council plans and how those things
work is actually simple. but most simple things are kind of complex.
I mean, you know this is not something that you necessarily can reduce down to okay,
A, B, C: 1,, 2, 3.. This is how you do it. What you have to understand is why we do it first.
So I want to zoom way, way out, because I think there's one thing that will really help you
work with your patroller's council to form plans and it will make the whole planning process a lot
less difficult. So zoom in way, way out. We're zooming way way out because I need to begin
with one observation, and I want to contextualize that observation first by saying I am not a
big fan of people my age, and I'm 56 years old. I'm not a big fan of people my age
making that myopic judgment that things were better when we were younger or things were
better at some time in the indeterminate past, because this can't possibly be true,
because no matter where you put a pin in the long pageant of history,
older people were always saying that about younger people. They were always complaining
that things used to be great, now they're horrible. I don't buy it. I don't think you
should buy it either. So this observation is not about how great things used to be and
everything's horrible now. No, I wanted to just observe that things have changed since I was
the age of my scouts in this world. There are more options and choices available to people now
than there were when I was their age. Now, that's just an observation. I'm certainly not saying
that more options are bad, because I don't think objectively, that they are. I'm just saying that
this may help you, if you're in my generation, begin to understand the particular things that
we're dealing with when we're asking our scouts to sit down and think through and plan things.
Okay, so we've got that right. Let's stay zoomed out for a moment and just look at the idea of a
society or a culture and the number of options that people within that society or culture have.
Every progressive society believes in the freedom of choice and that more choice equals more freedom,
and more freedom equals greater welfare for the citizens in that society. right,
But we're learning that simply increasing options does not necessarily improve our welfare or our
lives. The more options there are, the easier it is to regret anything that we did not choose.
It's kind of a paradox, isn't it? If you want to really delve into that subject,
try googling the paradox of choice, because there's a lot to be said about it. But for the purposes
of our conversation, let's just agree that more options does not always make things better,
and actually there are a set of circumstances where having more options can make things
worse. Okay, so we got that right. So now we can zoom in a little bit, because when I get
questions from scouts about the way scouts plan, I usually hear one of two things.
The first one is that they don't plan very well or at all, And the second one is that
they always plan the same things and they want me to give them new and creative program ideas
for their scouts to do. And I think a lot of that has to do with the idea that we're convinced
that the more choices they have, the better things will be. And I'm telling you that
that's not necessarily so. We're worried that our scouts will be bored or that we'll lose older
scouts because they're doing the same thing all the time. And I'm going to say that's not
necessarily so, because the answer to all this is relatively simple. Scouting is not a product
that we choose to purchase off a shelf that comes in a number of sizes and colors.
It's a really a very simple thing. Scouting is a progressive set of experiences designed
to achieve a specific aim. So when you sit down with your scouts to plan the first question you
want to ask is not: what are we going to do. The first question you want to ask is: who are we?
And in the podcast notes I will link to my 15 minute patrol leader training,
one side of an eight and a half by 11 sheet. That's all, And this talks about the answer
to that question. So, in short, the answer to that question is when we ask: Hey, who are we?
while we're scouts, Then we can ask ourselves: what do scouts do? And those things become our plans.
Okay, scouts go camping and they learn skills and apply them to their activities, They
explore hobbies and careers, They serve their community, They're responsible to organize
and plan their own activities And they put the scout oath and law into practice. So, if
you follow my logic, fairly simple- We don't begin by asking: what are we going to do.
We begin by saying: who are we? Well, we're scouts. What do scouts do?
Huh, well, we're going to do the things that scouts do. Now, if that's not making sense,
let me give you this analogy: A basketball team is made up of basketball players and they play
the game of basketball. They don't go to the basketball court and say: what are we going to
do? What game will we play? No, they know. they've all sorted this out when they signed up to
be a basketball player. They know the game that they're going to play. When they get to the
basketball court, they don't begin by painting boundaries on the floor and setting up the
baskets, because that's already been determined. They don't sit down and discuss what rules
they're going to play by, because the rules have already been set up right. So when the
patrol leaders council sits down to plan, they do not begin with a blank sheet of paper.
Their scouts and scouts do specific things. The field of play is already determined and
the rules are already written. So there are a set of constraints that we have when we're scouts,
And these constraints do not mean an unlimited number of choices. Remember what we talked
about a moment ago. The idea of an unlimited number of choices seems like a really great idea,
because more choices means more freedom. but we know that that breaks down at a certain point
And more choices is not more freedom. More choices may mean a really baffling ordeal of
trying to figure out which one to choose. And here's an analogy for you With that:
go to the grocery store and go to the salad dressing aisle. How many salad dressings are
there? 100? 200? Who can choose? If you were asked to make a choice, you got to pick one
salad dressing there for the rest of your life. Good luck with that, because as soon as you
make a choice, all of the other options are going to be staring back at you and make you
doubt whether or not you've made the right choice, And so that choice doesn't bring you
satisfaction and fulfillment. The choice brings you uncertainty. That's the nature of choosing,
and especially in the present culture that we're living in, The number of choices that we have
does not necessarily equal fulfillment and happiness. So the idea of unlimited choice
is not necessarily a positive one. When we sit down with our scouts and say
here's a blank piece of paper, You can do anything you want, No, we have a game,
We have rules, We have a field of play. It's already all set up, and within those constraints,
you see, we can make a number of choices, And the number of those choices is practically
unlimited. And alls we have to do to triage that number of choices is to ask ourselves some
questions, You know, can we afford to do that particular activity? Is it logistically possible?
And the whole idea of planning then becomes much simpler. So let's go back and review this.
First of all, I would say that one observable change that's happened since I was the age of my
scouts is the number of choices available to them have grown exponentially. not only you know
the number of salad dressings available at the grocery store, but the number of choices they
have in their lives for who they can be and what they will do, And what we do is. we normally
equate welfare with freedom, freedom with the number of choices, But we also understand that
just adding options to the list is not necessarily the best thing for us. An unlimited number of
choices can result in confusion and dissatisfaction, not focus and fulfillment. right, We don't begin
planning by asking: what do you want to do. We begin planning by asking who are we, And the
answer is: we're scouts. And then we ask ourselves: what do scouts do? Well, we have a defined
field of play and a defined set of rules by which we play our game, And so it is within those constraints
that we begin making choices about what we want to do. to dial all of this heady talk down to a very,
very practical level, Check out my 15 minute patrol leader training, because scouts do very
specific things to achieve a very specific set of aims, And so those are the things that we're
going to plan on doing. I hope that makes sense, And I'd like to hear your comments and
reactions and questions about what I've talked about today. So I want you to get in touch with me.
It's a very simple thing to do, And you're going to find out how to do it in just a moment.
Well, thank you for listening to this 306th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch. Go to scoutmastercgcom. You can read over 1600 articles in the blog
and listen to over 300 editions of the Scoutmaster podcast. You can also
subscribe to receive updates by email to the blog and the podcast, And you can touch
base with us through the vast panorama of social media. We've got 12,000 folks who
like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook, a chorus of 1500 tweeters on Twitter,
and we pin Pultritudinous pictures. We profit them publicly with 2400 other prolific
Pinterest pinners, And you can watch as the Scoutmaster CG on YouTube. But if none of that
really works for you, if Twitter makes you better, if you can't face Facebook,
you've no interest in Pinterest, and don't put the you in YouTube, That's all right,
Bunky, Just sail into the late 1990s and fire off an email. Yes, it's easy to do. I'm always
available at Clark at scoutmastercgcom, CLA RKE at scoutmastercgcom, And if none of that works,
scroll your question out on a piece of paper hermetically, seal it in a glass bottle and
bury it in any campfire circle. I will receive that question and send you an answer,
because I have agents everywhere. By now, it should be abundantly clear that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast and all the other stuff that we're doing is not
endorsed or sponsored by any scouting organization. Oh, my goodness. no, It's just me with a
microphone and a way to get on the internet and people listen to the things that I record,
And it's unbelievable, isn't it? And I just try and lend a hand to my fellow
scouts and have a little bit of fun along the way. And speaking of fun, here he is
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir, Until next time, everyone.